well with two hours notice uh 96
unaccompanied child migrants are placed
in a hotel in Hove the minister said
yesterday that they had special
Arrangements that they had special
facilities there was no special
facilities there the children were just
left there in very chaotic circumstances
the children did everything that was
asked of them it's slightly chaotic
organization around them I contacted
Sussex police I contacted Social
Services the council and the home office
the only organization that actually
understood the urgency of the
safeguarding challenges that was posed
by that were the Sussex police but they
didn't have the resources or the power
but I've got to just be really blunt
about this we've always known that
children are being coerced into crime we
know that disadvantaged kids are some
kids leaving school we understand county
lines operations but this has moved on
now because criminals people who are
running criminal gangs will go to where
vulnerable children are and they have
discovered that there are these hotels
housing dozens of children and they are
outside they are in the area they're in
the shops nearby and they are preying on
very vulnerable children I wanted and
the labor party wanted to get a 10-year
sentence for any adult that coerces a
child into crime I table that Amendment
on behalf of the labor party and it was
voted down by the Tories three years ago
I think we need to revisit this because
what I want to do and what the labor
party wants to do is to make children
repulsive to criminals because right now
they are disposable assets
it's really
um I mean you speak very powerfully
about it and particularly the case you
know in your own constituency as well
and so I guess is it part of the
criminal networks that we're seeing you
know obviously we know there's a lot of
you know young albanians coming to the
country trafficed over by people
Smugglers and are they then being picked
up effectively by criminal gangs in the
UK to what work in cannabis factories or
whatever it is well it doesn't matter
what nationality they are they go for
vulnerability so we know that there are
certain places where young people who
are very vulnerable go to sometimes it's
people referral units sometimes it
supports centers and youth groups for
children with certain characteristics
and we know that criminal gangs have
actually focused on some of those areas
to try and grab kids and attract kids
when they are leaving those areas well
there's this new thing now and these are
vulnerable kids who come from abroad who
are unaccompanied they're in unregulated
settings they are free to go English is
is not their first language this is a
new culture to them they are
specifically vulnerable sometimes
emotionally extremely vulnerable I've
been inside this so tell many times I
understand that I've met some of these
kids they're emotionally vulnerable but
they are physically vulnerable to
predators to criminal predators to being
coerced into crime well that's why we
need to make sure for example in this
country if you use a gun as a as a part
of your criminal Endeavor you're going
to prison for 10 years because we have a
10-year sentence for gun use whatever
you're using it for in but we don't have
anything like that for children so these
these criminals who are coercing
children into crime usually it's in the
drugs trade but for women and young
girls in particular we know it usually
ends up in some kind of sex trade as
well for if you are an adult who is
coercing children into crime in this way
usually you'll get done for the drugs
side of it but you will not get done and
prosecuted usually for what you've done
to the child and I think what you do to
a child when you do this sort of stuff
should be the headline crime and it
should be an absolutely such a repugnant
crime it should carry a very heavy
sentence if you are a criminal and you
coerce children into criminal Enterprise
you should go away for 10 years and you
should always have the record of what
you've done to a child over your head
for the rest of your life so yeah really
important story we're going to be doing
more on it later on in the program as
well
um just to move on to our lead story
today which is a decision by Germany and
the US to pledge battle tanks to Ukraine
and we've got president zelinski's
reaction to that as he was interviewing
with Kay now it comes after the UK was
the first Western Country to pledge
tanks do you give the government a bit
of credit we are at least leading the
way when it comes to Ukraine I
absolutely do give the government credit
for it we should be leading the way we
have some of the resources and the
equipment that's needed and we should be
fulsome in the way that we we do so I am
really pleased that Germany's got to
where it has I understand that Germany
has a very very different approach to
these issues use this is a very big
decision for Germany to take you know we
have different we were on different
sides of the second world war we both
have the second world war imprinted in
our culture in very very different ways
and I've just pointed out to some people
uh in the past couple of weeks that when
Nazi Germany invaded invaded Russia 27
million Russians died so in these issues
they they linger very very long there is
a lot of baggage that Germany carries
particularly when the discussion comes
to being offensive and not defensive in
the way that they tackle the defense of
their country so and and use of military
so I'm pleased they got to where they
are it's clear that they've been
thoughtful and it's clear also they've
worked with the US and they've unlocked
some investment in tanks from the US as
well so these are all positive things
but we need to see this not as
leadership but partnership Britain has
been very very good and fulsome but we
need to realize that if we're going to
repel Russia and we're going to keep
Russia contained into the future it it
can't be one country perceived as
leading we have to work in unison both
with NATO and other European countries
as well and perhaps as well being
prepared to be in it for the long haul I
thought was interesting the kremlin's
response saying these tanks will burn
down just like all the other ones except
they cost a lot and this will fall on
the shoulders of European taxpayers I
mean what would your message be to those
European taxpayers you know it is an
expensive War it is but we understand
that I don't think anybody now truly
believes that if Putin did manage to
Annex all of or invade and occupy all of
Ukraine that he would stop there Moldova
is next then we're on the border of the
European Union with Romania and other
countries none of those countries
themselves believe that that's where he
would stop now if you've if you speak to
countries like the Czech Republic or
representatives of in Poland they have
very specific living memory of invasions
from Russia in the former Soviet at
Union so this is felt very pungently
there so we need to make sure that we
secure our borders once again it is a
good investment and the thing about the
the quote from the Kremlin there is
we're very used to the rhetoric from the
Kremlin now and we have to take it into
that uh that perspective uh now nadims
at Harvey we know of course that's going
to be an inquiry into whether or not he
break the ministerial code I thought it
was interesting I asked Mel strides uh
what happens if he's found to be in
breached we should see you next slack
him and he said I think that would be a
very difficult finding not exactly a
rigging endorsement do you think there
is a possibility that he could stay on
at those circumstances well we know that
there is a possibility because this is a
Tory party we're talking about you know
we had uh Preeti Patel who broke the
ministerial code and she wasn't
sanctioned in any way shape or form we
know that other ministers have broken
the ministerial code and there's no
sanction so what's happened and this is
the thing that worries me the most about
Nadine zahawi other than the the issue
within its Singularity is the fact that
once again again people are looking on
at government and they're looking on at
Parliament and they're just saying they
were all the same I mean I guess what
Rishi sunak would say is that look he's
a different person to Boris Johnson you
know the examples you give went under
his Premiership
what I want to see is is action not
words I mean what Boris Johnson would
have done is exactly the same as Rishi
sunak by hiring Gavin Williamson putting
him in post when everybody knew he was
not fit for that office and he wouldn't
last long and he's going there was now
24 allegations against the Justice
secretary uh Dominic Robb this is
according to the guardian according to
the guardian yeah this evening you know
and that's rumbling on then we have the
issues with Sue Ella bravam and sacked
and then rehired six days later you know
no other this is unrecognizable to any
other Walk of Life than what we're
seeing here is unrecognizable to me in
the labor party this is one this is only
recognizable behavior in one part of our
political landscape and that's the Tory
party